guess that's the fakest thing in this
frame that artificial plant that
landline that's not plugged in or me no
hi my name is great I'll be done no you
know your life is different now first of
all I have new merch if you didn't know
this is one of the designs I'm really
proud of it I feel like it represents me
to my core the other designs are
available the links in description box
below because I have merged that means
that I understand that and I have the
ability to analyze that I want a biggest
back event the Met Gala you all know
about it I'm late to everything in my
life other than my period know how I
feel about that more than a couple of
few this is already incredibly stupid
but a perfect segue to talk about mecha
the met collar is basically a second
half of this sentence it's something I
don't know okay what is the mecha isn't
an award show what happens inside of
there it starts as a parade and then it
ends in like just a very expensive
escape room explain it to me otherwise
if you happen to know actually I don't
even want to know I don't give up
there's themes every year this year's
theme was camp
[Music]
nope camp meaning like campy ridiculous
extravagant extra hilarious at least
that's my understanding of it I actually
haven't googled what the actual meaning
was in relation to this event for camp
but again I don't care and I just
couldn't help myself I wanted to make a
video talking about some of the fashions
I tuned it out for your recommendations
on who I should review again I apologize
the one I won't know how to pronounce
people's name too
I won't know who people are and three I
will not talk about everyone you want me
to talk about so just like how everyone
in the world seems to be - Anna Wintour
I'm gonna be a constant disappointment
to you in this video so let's just jump
into it shall we
zendaya oh she showed up as Cinderella
and she had a full actual like this was
a show to me this is camp
this is silly this is ridiculous
Halloween meets EDM and I think it's
really great also is that what makalah
is it's just like a Halloween party for
really really rich people perhaps maybe
we'll understand it more as we go
through these outfits fashions looks
costumes I think she totally understands
the absurd ridiculousness
of the camp theme and obviously that
behind her behind her knows that she
knows cute Kylie Jenner wow this looks
like you're fisting - sniffles kisses is
that camp I don't know but you got two
camps right here that will cause some
pitch tents I feel let me you kendall
Jenner
again Vegas showgirl you look like sexy
gritty you Darren Criss you look like a
very flamboyant ringmaster like someone
in a Vegas show at Cirque du Soleil that
would like really make someone kind of
uncomfortable in the audience okay new
theory is the Met Gala just like Cirque
du Soleil for people that can't do like
acrobatics I hope that they have like
lobster or crab claws because you got
your bib all set and ready to go yeah
speaking of Vegas the Queen has arrived
Celine Dion this is how you do can't be
Vegas showgirl I don't know what this is
I love it this is like if Falkor from
the neverending story became a Vegas
showgirl and then like fully jammed a
fork into an electrical socket yeah Ryan
Murphy well you look like you are being
first out of a vajazzle vagina this is
camp to me this is ridiculous it's like
Ask Jeeves getting pushed out of a dime
encrusted [ __ ] why not yeah Laverne Cox
this looks like you're crowning out of
like a very goth majid I don't know why
that's where my brains at now it looks a
little bit like your sharding in the
front pollution queef but make it
fashion and she didn't do Harry Styles
I'm biased to this I love Harry Styles
and this I don't know if it's camp but
he's wearing lace and a Pearl Earring
and he's got it's just I like it a lot
I'm gonna have to cool down all right
cue Billy Porter my god I'm obsessed I
just binge watch the whole first season
of Poe's the other day and I loved it
highly recommend if you haven't seen it
our Lady Jaye recorded an episode of not
too deep but thus it'll be up in a
couple weeks get ready oh and I love him
so much he's a Phoenix not even rising
from ashes like literally rising from
diamonds made from ash already into some
other new beautiful gemstone that
doesn't even exist yet that he's
introducing all of us peasants to he's
like just a human Golden Snitch we're
all trying to catch him you the peanut
young go I love this this feels like
camp to me her hair it's just silly and
ridiculous and wonderful and she just is
absolutely stunning she looks like some
like Michael's craft store tie-dye crepe
paper butterfly rising out of her cocoon
and I loved every second of it huge
Janelle Monae she's perfect
I saw the video that her tit I actually
blinked it's true so her tits were
winking at you she gets to say my eyes
are up here
anyone that took
- this event is gonna have a real
interesting time like just try doing
this for a little bit I don't want to
anymore
and she did that all goddamn night yeah
Kacey Musgraves she showed up as this
massimo mashup mop whatever you're not
here for the correct pronunciation of
designer names inspired Barbie and it's
fantastic this is another confirmation
that perhaps the Met Gala is celebrity
Halloween this is very campy she looked
just like the Barbie doll and she came
with this like completely vapid vacant
stare that's almost creepy cute Liz oh
oh god this is fantastic
you like it snuffleupagus was like
smoking weed in its room with its
friends and then all sudden like there's
a pounding at the door and it's just
this like beautiful like but it
aggressively charismatic and personable
voice on the other side there was like
are you smoking in here and then the
door flung open it was just this and you
have been snuffleupagus is mom the whole
time you got a furry peppermint cute
Nicki Minaj whoa you look like if the
ballerina from like a little girl's
jewelry box decided it wanted to give
[ __ ] tonight you Tessa Thompson well
this is like a little bo-peep went to
like the big city and then came back to
her farm and told her parents like
surprise I'm a dominatrix now okay bye
you guys cool handling the Sheep I had a
bunch of like um like human butts I need
to go with you Haley Bieber whoa this is
like if your Breakfast at Tiffany's
inspired Barbie doll was like I'm gonna
go get oh no I saw a lot of people
saying that Haley got the idea of camp
because she has a rhinestoned
song poking out of her dress and that
you know is so silly that means that 80%
of my high school graduating class was
real can't be yeah cardi B yeah here we
go
I saw a lot of people tweet admit this
elephant reminded them that they had to
go buy tampons
it is like Joan of Arc meets a period
stayin sleeping bag cute
Ezra Miller
this is crazy and very campy and also
really gives me vertigo I love
everything about it I also love that
I've never thought to do a makeup look
like this because I hate when people
make eye contact with me and this is
impossible to make eye contact
you're a genius cute Michael Urie I love
this prom yin-yang and it's fantastic I
love the heel with the suit and the boot
with the dress and the clutch with the
suit and the makeup with the suit and
the non makeup with the dress this is
fantastic
how do I register for your camp because
I'd like to spend my summers there cute
Hailee Steinfeld steamed students beans
these things still please so I can take
a photo oh I can't got it oh she's in on
the joke look at it it looks like both
her hair and her dress and both gone
through humidity yeah JLo Wow you look
like a diamond monster came all over
your head I mean you look stunning
cute empowered deviled eggs I love this
this is like some shroom driven
children's movie character like this is
I think what Willy Wonka's wife might
have looked like you also how did you
get through any doorways gigi hadid
oh this is what nightmares look like
this is like the upset wife that a
member of Blue Man Group has to come on
I don't know why this is scary if a
magician's assistant like died and then
like rose from the dead in like Walking
Dead fashion like this is what I would
imagine seeing you Eddy Perry of course
of course she I mean what else is she
gonna do her normal aesthetic everyday
aesthetic is camp I saw all the Beauty
and the Beast references that were
happening and this really like you
should be hanging up in like Lisa
Vanderpump's home somewhere also I loved
in her after party outfit was literally
like a giant Halloween costume of a
hamburger and I found this picture of
her talking to Celine Dion and it is so
wonderful this looks like a concerned
mom scolding they're like high as a kite
daughter about
it's you can't wear that to prom yeah
jared leto someone got head at this
event not original I'm convinced that
the Met Gala is just expensive fashion
Halloween that's all it is is the inside
just a giant luxurious party city that
you guys all return your costumes to by
psychoshy
you look like a fanciest ace bandage
cute okay there we go I said we were
gonna go fast but you know there was so
much to get through and again I
apologize for obviously not talking
about the people that you probably
wanted me to and obviously repeating
things you've probably seen said about
these people are ready because I'm late
to the game on this I hope you guys
enjoyed this review of the Met Gala 2019
if you did give this video a thumbs up
hit that Bell notification or button or
whatever with a system YouTube currently
has because I'm clearly out of the loop
for being reminded of when I post videos
because I post them but then obviously
would make you want to subscribe to this
YouTube channel so do that if you
haven't already also all the links for
my new merch is down below and other
than that Kim Kardashian and I don't
think this is camp but your body looks
like ridiculous so maybe that is campy
in and of itself sometimes I rip open
Amazon boxes and like the cardboard
likes plays everywhere and then I leave
it on my deck for too long and my
sprinklers go on and then it makes it
wet and then it gets all like squishy
and wrinkly and all that so this kind of
reminds me of that cute